la ferme collective un moyen de
favoriser la consommation locale
ces changements de ce dit pays-bas
appartiennent à deux cents familles de
la région
elles ont chacune investi 2000 euros
pour acheter une vingtaine d'hectares de
terres agricoles
on y cultive une cinquantaine de
variétés de légumes et on y élève des
vaches et cochons et des pôles une fois
par semaine les membres de la
coopérative venir remplir leurs paniers
en échange d'un montant de 11 euros par
personne un investissement qui en vaut
la peine puisque les produits de la
ferme représente 60% de leur
alimentation
manger local permet de réduire la
pollution causée par le transport des
arguments sur de longues distances